-Welcome. And thank you
for watching
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
Here we are.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's get to some news.
Well, guys, today, California
voted on whether or not
to recall their governor,
Gavin Newsom.
Yeah. Newsom was like,
"You can't just get rid of
your governor.
That's crazy."
Then New Yorkers were like,
"Eh, it's not as crazy
as you think."
Just click the link, yeah.
The recall comes after
major criticism
of Newsom's handling of
the pandemic.
Meanwhile, Florida governor
Ron DeSantis is going,
"We don't have recalls
here, do we?
We don't, right?
Whew!"
As of right now,
it looks like Gavin Newsom
will remain governor.
Newsom spent the day...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...spent the day thanking
his staff and supporters.
And they were like,
"Well, you should really thank
Dwayne Johnson for
not running against you,
because we like you, but we
would have voted for him, so..."
Newsom's main opponent was
a conservative talk-show host
named Larry Elder.
And I think he knew that
he was in trouble,
because last night --
and this is true --
Elder actually posted on
his website asking supporters
to report fraud that resulted
in Newsom winning.
This is before
people started voting.
Wow. Nothing says confidence
like throwing in the towel
before you even get to the ring.
You're like, "You know, I think
you're going to make
the wrong call on this."
Basically, Larry Elder
is the friend
who unplugs the Nintendo
right before
you beat him in "Mario Kart."
He's like, "Technically,
it doesn't count as
a win, because...
Meanwhile,
former President Trump
also weighed in by releasing
statement after statement
claiming that the recall
election in California
would be rigged.
Yeah, without social media,
Trump is doing whatever
he can to get the message out.
He even wore it on a dress
to last night's Met Gala.
-Wow!
-Can you believe --
a night out like that?
Some news from Russia.
Vladimir Putin
is now self-isolating
after several members
of his inner circle
tested positive for COVID.
It's weird.
I believe this is
the first time Putin
has ever made himself disappear.
Russia is a little strange.
It's the only place where
you don't feel so good
and you're like,
"Whew, it's only COVID."
Ahh!
I had tea with Putin the other
day, and I thought -- Yeah.
Whoa-ho-ho-ho!"
Wow! Yeah, you can tell Putin
is nervous about it,
because the Kremlin
just released a photo
of him stealing dewormer pills
from his horse.
[ Russian accent ]
Spit out. Spit out.
Well, last night, the Met Gala
was held here in New York City.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And there -- Yeah.
And there was some wild looks.
One of my favorites was
Kim Kardashian,
who showed up wearing this
full-body black shroud.
Look at this.
Yeah, you know that you're
a massive celebrity
when you show up in that
and people are like,
"Oh, it's Kim Kardashian."
Meanwhile, rapper Nicki Minaj
made headlines
last night when
she announced that
she wouldn't get vaccinated
for the event.
But her reasoning
for not getting the shot
was pretty strange.
Listen to this.
-Rapper Nicki Minaj
says that her cousin's friend --
And she put this on
social media.
She has 22 million followers.
She said
he has swollen testicles
after taking the vaccine.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cymbal crash ]
-Did that guy know you're
supposed to get the shot --
You're supposed to
get the shot in your arm.
He knows...
I'll send her a text later.
-Wow.
And she didn't go to
the Met Ball.
Odd.
[ Laughter ]
-No, it's too close.
-Yeah.
-Guys, listen to this.
Fireball is releasing
their own kegs that contain
5 liters of whiskey
called FireKegs.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Look at this.
-Oh, no!
-I'm actually relieved, because
when I saw Fireball trending,
I thought something else
happened to
Nicki Minaj's cousin's friend.
Get this -- I read about
a group of scientists
who are trying to bring back the
long-extinct woolly mammoth.
Here's what's going to happen.
The woolly mammoth
will come back
and immediately start doing
sponsored posts for Gillette.
Just trust me.
Yep, after they bring back a
beast from the Ice Age,
they're gonna work on
bringing back ice.
[ Light laughter ]
Bring back ice.
And, finally,
a company in Berlin --
You guys like ice?
Remember ice?
Finally, a company in Berlin
just secured $50 million
in funding to expand their
lab-grown-cheese business.
Meanwhile, in America, we've had
lab-grown cheese for years.
It's called Velveeta.
Hey, we have a great show.
Give it up for The Roots!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ I'm on a mission that some
people think is impossible ♪
♪ But when I'm swingin' my
swords, they're all choppable ♪
♪ I be the body-dropper,
the heartbeat-stopper ♪
♪ Child-educator
and head-amputator ♪
♪ Brothers' styles is old
like Mark 5 sneakers ♪
♪ Never weak ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What a show
we have for you tonight.
She is one of the biggest
supermodels in the world
and she's got a new tequila
called 818 available now.
Kendall Jenner is here!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ow!
-Come on!
-Plus, his new cookbook,
"Antoni: Let's Do Dinner,"
is out today.
Antoni Porowski is here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ow-whoo!
-Whoo!
-Antoni Porowski.
I love this dude.
And it's Broadway Week here at
"The Tonight Show."
Broadway is coming back.
It is back.
And every night this week,
we have in-studio performances
from some of the
biggest shows on Broadway.
We love Broadway so much.
Tonight, we have Tony nominee
Adrienne Warren from
"Tina: The Tina Turner Musical"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Get ready!
Tonight.
I was at the
Met Gala last night.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I was invited. Thank you.
I was very -- Table 22.
This is my table card,
just saying,
just to prove that I was there.
Table 22 was --
This was the party table.
-Wow!
-I was at --
-Who was there with you?
-My corner of the table was
Pete Davidson...
-Love him.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-...Amandla Stenberg,
Lil Uzi Vert.
-Ooh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Very funny, by the way.
He's a trickster, that guy.
It was just --
But it was amazing.
Serena Williams was by me.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You just saw
every single person.
And Erykah Badu
was there at my table.
And, yeah, so, we went.
I got very -- I was at
Thom Browne's table.
Thom Browne, amazing designer.
I love that guy.
And very lucky to be -- Here's
me in the Thom Browne tux,
just to say.
-Ooh-la-la!
-Not too shabby. There it is.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. And they --
He took care of me, and they --
It's extra-COVID-safe.
It was like four --
I had to do this giant app
where they scan my face
and then had to re-scan my face.
And then I had to take
a selfie to prove
that my face
was scanning my face.
But it was good. I felt safe.
At the end of the night,
I was leaving.
You know, everyone is going
home, and I go, "Yeah."
And there's, like, these
barriers of bushes and stuff
so that, you know,
everyone stays in line
and all that stuff.
But there was fans kind of
across the street
taking photos and stuff.
And I jumped over one of
the fences just to...
to go say "hi"
to the fans across the street.
So I just wanted to make sure
I got over there.
-Oh, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
They're getting some ice.
-I was sitting there --
So, I'm at the table.
I'm talking to Pete Davidson,
and we're talking.
And he goes -- They
go, "Please take your seats.
The entertainment
is about to begin."
And I go, "Okay, great."
And it could be anything.
Sometimes, it's a circus.
Who knows what is it is?
Sometimes, it's a singer,
whatever.
And they go,
"Please take your seats.
The entertainment
is about to begin."
And Pete goes,
"I got to go the bathroom."
I go, "No, you can't.
I wouldn't do it now.
They just said the entertainment
is about to begin."
He goes,
"Yeah, I got to go, man."
I go, "I don't know if I would.
I would stay here.
Wait to the end
of the entertainment.
He goes,
"I'm just going to do it now,
because they're probably just
going to announce it again,
and I'm just --"
I go, "Alright, go for it."
So, he gets up and leaves.
He was -- You know, he was
fashionable and looked great.
He leaves.
I go, "Alright, whatever."
And as he leaves, maybe
30 seconds later, I hear --
[ Imitates
marching band playing ]
A marching band
comes through the exit
that he was going to
the bathroom.
And there's Pete Davidson
standing there, 6'8",
with, like, white hair going...
In the middle of
a marching band.
I go, "Oh, my God!"
The ultimate bust of all time.
He's like, "Well, I guess
that was a bad idea."
Anyway, I wanted to thank
Anna Wintour,
I wanted to thank Thom Browne
for inviting me and having me.
It was a big night for me and it
was a big night for New York.
I loved it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Guys, like I said earlier,
everyone's talking about
today's recall election
in California.
There are a lot of candidates
trying to replace
Governor Gavin Newsom,
so we wanted to break it all
down for you.
It's time for "Fast Stats."
Here we go.
-♪ Learn some fast stats,
fast stats ♪
-First, we have Larry Elder.
His job is
conservative radio host.
Party trick -- Eating
an entire apple in two bites.
Previous job --
Playing the principal
on a Nickelodeon show where
he gets slimed every episode.
[ Applause ]
Next, we have Rhonda Furin.
Job -- Self-employed.
Former job --
Background exerciser
in every '80s workout video.
Often mistaken for --
A woman on a "Dateline" episode
who definitely
killed her husband.
[ Applause ]
Next up, it's Kevin Faulconer.
Job --
Former mayor of San Diego.
Wants to know -- "What's gonna
get you in the driver's seat
of this 2005
Hyundai Elantra today?"
First thing he'll do
in the office --
Even out his spray tan.
[ Applause ]
Then we have Robert Newman.
Job -- Farmer.
Currently --
FaceTiming his grandchildren
too close to the camera.
Last seen --
as a signed head shot
on the wall
of an Italian restaurant.
[ Applause ]
And, finally, it's David Moore.
Job -- Teacher.
Last person he upset --
His barber.
Catalogue model for --
Clip-on ties.
Campaign slogan --
"Don't call them comic books,
they're graphic novels."
This has been "Fast Stats,"
everybody.
Thank you very much.
Hey, we had some shocking --
some sad news today.
It was told to us that
Norm Macdonald,
a great comedian, passed away
today at the age of 61.
And, gosh, you know him.
You love him.
-Yeah.
-And he's just one of
the greatest comedians ever,
and, God,
we're going to miss him.
He was a friend of the show --
family, really, to us.
We've known him forever.
I remember Norm -- I would do
impressions of Norm.
In like the late '80s, I would
videotape every comedian.
They had all these comedy shows
on all the time.
Like, it was on every channel,
and I would know everyone's act.
Judy Tenuta, Jann Karam.
Everyone's act I would know.
And this guy comes on,
Norm Macdonald.
This guy -- "Hey, crazy accent."
And he's so funny and he was so
cool-looking and so confident.
And he told this bit about
a wiener dog.
I don't know if
you know this bit.
He's like, "Hey,
he's trying to get a dog,
you know, at the dog market.
It's crazy, the dog market.
It's really expensive
to buy a dog, you know?
I'm not telling you anything
you don't know.
Dog market --
A lot of money for a dog.
You know, you pay like 500 bucks
for a dog.
You know, I was thinking,
if I was to get a dog,
it'd probably be maybe
like 1 buck,
maybe 2 bucks max,
you know, for a dog.
You know, they go,
"Oh, you got to get this dog.
You get a, uh, pit bull.
You get a pit-bull dog.
You know, it's 500 bucks
for a pit-bull dog.
If you get a pit bull, it will
take care of your valuables.
Do I look like
I own any valuables?
If I get a pit bull,
probably the most valuable thing
I'll own is the pit bull.
Then you got to get another dog
to take care of the pit bull.
When I was growing up,
you know, we had a Dober-man.
That was the most dangerous dog.
Dober-man was
the most dangerous dog.
It'd rip your throat out,
you get a Dober-man.
Yeah, if I want a dog,
I want a dog I can take out.
I want a dog
that won't mess with you.
You know, if I get a dog,
I'd get, like, a wiener dog.
A wiener dog
won't rip your throat out.
You know,
unless you're maybe, like,
laying on the ground
sleeping or something.
Wiener dog come over and start
nibbling on your throat.
You know, you wake up, 'Hey, get
out of here, you wiener dog!
Who do you think you are,
a pit bull?'"
Anyways, that was
one of the bits.
I memorized his whole act.
I loved him.
And then I got --
Obviously, "Weekend Update,"
he changed the whole game.
And I remember just getting on
"Saturday Night Live."
And I was in L.A.
and I went to some hotel.
And I'm walking past the lobby,
and who's having breakfast?
Norm Macdonald.
I go, "Oh, my gosh."
So I go over.
I'm freaking out, 'cause
he's one of my comedy idols.
And I go over to him --
I go, "Oh, Norm --"
I go, "Hi.
My name is Jimmy Fallon.
I just love you so much.
You're the best."
And he was eating breakfast
with Bob Newhart,
and he looked at me he goes,
"The best?"
[ Laughter ]
"This is Bob Newhart.
I go, "I didn't know it was
Bob Newhart that --
I didn't know you were
eating breakfast with Bob.
Yes, you are the best.
Sorry, Mr. Newhart.
You actually are the best,
but, Norm, you are --"
You know, it's like --
But that's so --
He didn't want him
to just take the thing
that he was the best.
But he was a comic's comic,
and everyone absolutely
loved him, top to bottom.
And he will be missed.
Yeah.